a panel of medical experts recommends a
major change to breast cancer screening
in draft guidelines released just
yesterday CBS News medical contributor
Dr Celine gounder is here with us she's
also by the way editor at large for
public health at kff we're glad you're
here Dr gounder so what are the
recommendations this is big yeah so this
is the U.S preventive Services Task
Force this is one of the many
organizations that makes recommendations
on breast cancer and other kinds of
screening and they are now recommending
that all women start breast cancer
screening by the age of 40 and that they
get 350. it used to be 50 right and that
they get their mammograms at least every
other year why the change do you think
now well we've seen an increase in
breast cancer rates among women under 50
over the last several years particularly
since 2015 and we've also had these
really sticky Health disparities we
haven't been able to move the needle on
the rate of breast cancer mortality
deaths from breast cancer among black
women versus white women so this is an
effort to try to improve those
disparities what are the recommendations
every other year you get the screening
every other year at a minimum at a
minimum okay and insurance will cover
mammograms and other breast cancer
screenings starting from the age of 40
every year so if you were to want more
frequent breast cancer screening you do
have that option will insurance cover
these insurance will cover mammograms
every year starting from age 40. what
may or may not be covered depending on
the state you live in is the other
testing like ultrasounds and MRIs and
what do we keep hearing about women that
have dense breast cancer tissue will
this have an impact on that is that one
of the reasons too so something like
half of women have dense breasts and
your breasts get less dense as you age
but we know that's a risk factor for
breast cancer the recommendations are
the same for now but more research is
needed so you would say this is a good
thing I don't see a downside to getting
it earlier do you I don't see a downside
particularly given the data suggests
that you can save lives by doing this
yes yes yes yes I think this is great
news actually thank you very much Dr
Celine gander